yeah how do you budget
for all your animals you get a lot of
animals over there how does it work
there's no budget for the animals
there's none so it's just spend what you
got to spend you're not figuring it out
like i have to constantly work to figure
out new ways to make more money because
i just want to give them the best life
possible you know so like i'm not going
to say hey you have like after this
you're done you know it's like bro how
can i look at my dog and say yo i'm not
going to get you the best food i could
possibly get i freaking love you i will
go get you all the food you want you
want chew toys you want coconuts you
want fresh water i'm gonna give it to
you if i i'm gonna figure it out and you
have how many animals in total give or
take 100 more or less 100 animals so
that's going to cost
10 grand a month more or less i don't
know how am i going to count it you
still don't even worry about it you
don't even count the numbers why i don't
know i mean you kind of do what you
think i want that hurt in my heart
to see that number i don't want to see
you you don't want to see the number i
want to see the number and i don't want
to i don't wanna oh i don't wanna ever
have a thought in my mind of saying i
wouldn't spend this type of money let me
get a thought for you
let's say you can get a brand let's just
hypothetically speaking to pay for all
your expenses to feed your animals and
your brand sponsors you and they say
well how much do you want for us to feed
your animals you got to have a number in
mind you got to say well it cost me 20
grand a month to feed the animals so
brands we're looking at you out there
we're going to figure that we'll circle
back to this 10 dogs
10 dogs 25 snakes yes 30 lizards yes
i mean i don't even know how many
turtles you have names for all of them
yeah
mostly all of them okay you know some
snakes i don't really name all my snakes
okay some have different names because
they're
special special you know they're special
um
what's the next animal that you're gonna
get sorry adam yeah it's okay
i want a hippo
baby hippos are so cute right oh my god
is there any chance you could get a
hitbox 100
wow do i need a hippo no no
should i have it absolutely not um do i
want hippo for sure
[Music]